it is inevitable that fans will want
what is arguably the game console of a
generation to go out with a bang
following the stellar performances of
first party exclusives like the last of
us part 2 and god of war it is now
sucker punch productions turn at the bed
with ghost of tsushima
before we begin if you haven't already
show us some love by subscribing to our
youtube channel following us on facebook
or visiting our website so you can stay
updated on the latest geeky news and
tidbits
an action-adventure epic that brings
gamers back to tsushima island in the
1200s it is against this backdrop that
we are introduced to jin sakai
the culture of the samurai and the
unrelenting aggressiveness of the mongol
invaders
it is clear this is a force that the
japanese samurai has never encountered
brutal zealous and most of all willing
to win at all costs
such disdain for the traditions of
honourable combat sets the stage for the
rebirth of jin sakai as the titular
ghost of tsushima if he is to win this
war
this examination the duality is
reflected throughout the 30-40 hour
journey that takes you across tsushima
from struggling to abandon his values to
fully embracing the gifts at his
disposal
jin sakai evolves from one of the few
remaining samurai into a whirlwind of
destruction fear and intimidation
aided on his journey by allies and
hunted down at every corner by his
enemies the people of sushima do more
than their fair share of being great
characters
jin sakai's growth and development is
driven by player agency yet he remains
his own person
growing out of naivety into one who can
shoulder the heaviest of
responsibilities
the people or girls of sushima help to
tell a story that is captivating from
start to end
through them you will learn about how
actions have far reaching consequences
the need for sacrifice and the extent to
which people go to just to survive the
horrors of war
these constant reminders of working
towards something bigger than oneself
makes ghost of tsushima one of the most
interesting narratives in 2020 speaking
of tales there are plenty of activities
you can get yourself into throughout the
three large regions that make up
tsushima island
while you can barrel through the main
story content and work towards your
revenge this is a gigantic world rife
with opportunities
[Music]
ghost of tsushima issues a traditional
waypoint system that points you towards
an objective rather the woe itself acts
as a signpost directing your attention
at the nearest point of interest sure
you can drop a pin on the map and let
the wind guide you but pay attention and
you will see plenty along the way
smokestacks can mean a settlement in
need of help flocks of birds will guide
you towards a peaceful spot to compose a
haiku or stumble on pond a mystical fox
then that can lead you to an inari
shrine there is simply so much to do and
so much to see in this world
there are resources to collect in order
to upgrade your gear hidden collectibles
that grant both rewards and lore
lighthouses to light hot springs to
enjoy and bamboo strikes to complete
the rarer mythic tales speak of legends
of all which hides some of the best
rewards in the game it is highly
recommended to get these done as soon as
you can
each of these side activities provide
some gameplay bonuses should you seek
them out and will make your time and
goals of sushima easier
however you can also just ignore them
and grind it out the world is your
oyster
[Music]
and what a gorgeous oyster it turned out
to be ghost of tsushima is a struggling
beautiful game and sucker punch has done
a fantastic job at imbuing a sense of
wonder and spirituality into almost
every facet of the world
from the guiding wind to the wildlife
that inhabits the island there are many
moments where you would just want to sit
back and admire the scene before you
galloping deer rampaging bears and while
balls can be seen going about their
business
spot a golden bird and follow it as it
reveals the secrets of the island
the aforementioned foxes and flocks of
birds have their own treasures to share
and the fireflies that light up the
night are just wonderful
add them to the large greenery you will
find at every turn in ghost of tsushima
and it becomes a masterful painting come
to life
this is one game that demands a photo
mode and thankfully sucker punch has
provided one with great features to help
you capture these memorable moments
of course the boko ghoshima is all about
action
taking back your island from the mongols
will require the smealing of blood and
there is plenty of that going around the
mongols have taken over many important
settlements camps and towns and have
roving patrols to keep the people in
check
the fallout from the invasion has also
led to the emergence of bandits and
other near the wells taking advantage of
the unrest and pillaging unprotected
areas of the island
how appropriate then to have most of
these problems solved with the swing of
the katana
as a trained samurai jin is no stranger
to the blade in fact he is a formidable
force however to master the blade
samurai are taught to control their
emotions tampered with patience and
discipline
that is a lesson players must learn as
well for recklessness will cost you
dearly
observing your opponents and picking the
right moments to strike with the right
tool will keep you alive to fight
another day
as the story detects it is often gin
going up against overwhelming numbers
and mastering how to fight is key to
that
as you learn different stances to take
on different kinds of foes you'll be
staggering them delivering kicks and
taking full advantage of their mistakes
technique points earned will help unlock
more devastating attacks and defensive
options there will even the playing
field
be it swordsmen spearmen hulking brutes
or shield carriers they will stand
little chance against a seasoned warrior
it is a marvel to behold as you take on
groups of enemies that require different
solutions switching stances on the fly
and delivering the fatal blow to each of
them
swordplay is but one of your tools as
jin also gains access to other useful
equipment throughout his journey
kunai can hurt enemies at the distance
and open them up while smoke bombs and
sticky bombs can obscure and tin out the
numbers
ranged weapons also come into play with
jin well versed in the art of archery
defensively jin will also build out his
arsenal with some truly grand armor
every set that you will obtain comes
with its own benefits attained through
upgrading you will come a long way from
dawning broken equipment to transform
into an imposing figure wearing awesome
gear by the time you reach the
conclusion of gozotsushima
for situations that require a more
stealthy touch the ghost side of jin
comes into play
distractions in the form of firecrackers
and wind chimes assassination and even
poison are tools in this war against the
mongol the more you can take out without
drawing attention the easier it is when
gene needs to emerge from the shadows
his ability to climb swing and blend
into tall grass allows for jinn to
approach situations in a multitude of
ways
rooftops and elevated positions will
give you a better view
while jin can rely on the focus hearing
skill to review enemy positions before
making your move
if you are master of conduct the
standard mechanic will be your go-to
approach enemies and proclaim your
intention time it right and you'll be
looking at instant kills in the coolest
of fashion
however you can also pick off enemies
one by one moving in from the periphery
until there is none standing it is
entirely up to you
on occasions goes to tsushima will pit
you against other experts of swordplay
and duels
the pseudo boss fights are a treat
requiring you to bring all your skills
to the table in order to win
there are no tricks to be used in duos
only proper timing on both offensive and
defensive fronts they are satisfying to
engage in and a true expression of your
might as a warrior
on the technical side of things goes to
tsushima definitely has its ups and
downs
animations can sometimes glitch out with
mongols getting flung high into the air
by dead bears or the hilt of jin's
katana poking out of his cape
there were some quests that failed to
progress with missing npcs and point of
interest
but those were all fixable with a quick
load of the checkpoint
however the plus side is that ghost of
shima has little to no loading at all
even fast traveling from one point to
another on the huge map takes only as
much time as it was spent reading one of
the many useful tips the devs have
provided
it is simply amazing to see this in
action and with the upcoming playstation
5 set to surpass all that with its
technology this is a treat saver for the
current generation
the graphical fidelity of the
environment is also amazing to look at
as a whole from the wind blowing through
the leaves to falling foliage most of
ghosa's female can be captured and hung
as a lovely piece of art the kurosawa
mode that gives the game the cinematic
feel is extraordinary
but it is also a huge miss if you do not
see the life and color that went into
this world
music in ghostoshima also goes a long
way in setting the mood
the crescendos that accompany a combat
scenario and the soothing tones of more
meditative sequences embody the spirit
and core values of the game perfectly
[Music]
fight me
and the many moments of reflection
afforded to players throughout their
adventure will push you to examine your
own life in contrast jinns
the entire experience of ghost of
tsushima is one that will be enjoyed by
most
jin sakai's tale of transforming into
the ghosts and pushing back the mongols
is an epic adventure that contains great
storytelling delightful combat and
interesting stealth mechanics
the game's reliance on emergent
exploration is wonderfully realized and
provides plenty of incentive for players
to explore an island that might just be
a little too big
it is likely that comparisons will be
made between goals of shima and the
later entries in the ss and screed
scenes
in fact it can be argued that ghost of
tsushima has everything great without
some of the more niggling bits that hold
back the ubisoft titles if you have been
yearning for the assassins to visit
japan it has already been done and a new
bar has been set even as fans await a
new console goes to sushima is here to
remind us that this current generation
is still going strong
sucker punch productions have definitely
made something fantastic in a fitting
swan song for one of the greatest
consoles in history
a feeding playstation first party
exclusive to arrive for the ps4
goes to fushima is an epic adventure
that has all the right ingredients for
major success for more details on gozo
tsushima and other video game news check
out the links in the description below
until the next one stay geeky
[Music]